there are reports Iranian forces are
using bullets and tear gas an
anti-government protesters in Iran this
morning those demonstrations are
starting their fourth week activists say
at least 185 protesters have been killed
by Iranian authorities many of the
victims are young adults and children
Roxanna saberi reports
15 year old
nikarani was full of life
appeared after joining the protests in
Iran days later her mom was in mourning
authorities claimed Nika fell to her
death from a tall building
but her mom says that's a lie she was
killed by blows to her head
since the Nationwide demonstrations
began in mid-september several other
young protesters have lost their lives
like 16 year olds Ismail zadeh 22 year
old Hadi snajafi and 22 year old Masa
amini whose death in police custody
sparked the unrest verification Human
Rights Watch researcher Teresa parifar
has documented the deaths of dozens of
protesters of all ages
what are the main tactics that the
Iranian authorities are using against
protesters a lot of reports views tear
gas use of batons Security Forces use of
shotguns assault weapons the brutal
measures have scared many Iranians into
staying home
work even if you honk your horn in
support of the protests they identify
you this woman said afraid to go on
camera
but she added young people seemed
Fearless
this week's school girls chanted death
to the dictator
told a member of the besiege militia to
get lost and spray-painted women life
freedom on the walls Fed Up and angry
with the ruling regime many feel they
have nothing to lose for CBS Saturday
morning Roxanna siberi London